the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group we have a
governor and legislature
focused on protecting their own party
[Music]
tonight on politics now sheriff joe
lombardo starts his run for governor
we're going to break down his
announcement plus
we need to put some money into this
create an organization that acts as a
central belly button
and force all these other government
agencies to start cooperating
the government investigation into ufos
our own george knapp breaks down what is
and
isn't in a new congressional report and
this
infrastructure is very important because
we have to import everything we don't
make anything
except maybe dreams come true on capitol
hill will an infrastructure bill
ever get passed we look at the latest
maneuverings in congress
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler vice president kamala
harris is in las vegas this week
she was scheduled to speak at the
carpenters union earlier today at sunset
and valley view down in henderson
we have some video from her last visit
here in march there you see it
part of the biden administration's
promotion of the american rescue plan
now her speech was taped after when we
taped this show we will have the latest
for you of course at 8newsnow.com but
the big news in politics this week clark
county sheriff joe lombardo finally made
it official
he is running for governor the i-team's
david charns was
at the campaign kickoff this week david
and let's break down what was a pretty
big decision and a pretty big
announcement yeah we sort of knew it was
coming right very much but this is the
this is the official mark here
the speech was over at rancho high
school where lombardo himself graduated
from several decades ago
he is a republican of course and it was
very clear that the backbone of this
campaign
was that he plans to run as the law and
order candidate take a listen
what we currently have is we have a
paradigm or we have a sense
up in carson city that we're more
concerned with felons rights
lessening penalties associated with
crime and handcuffing the police and
that's a
that's a paradigm or that that's a
program that just
doesn't breed success into the future we
have to change that
we have to be more objective in how we
look at that yes police reform is needed
and we we i appreciate that and we have
looked at that
but it's acting too fast we've created
an environment where the police are
handcuffed and they
have an inability to do their job it's
interesting to hear him say that because
as sheriff he's been pretty open about
the idea of police reform and being
somewhat supportive of some of the
measures that his own department has
already put into place but
he's trying to set himself apart clearly
from governor steve sisilak
we know the sheriff has a long career in
law enforcement here in the valley
what did he say about other important
issues in nevada when it comes to maybe
education
well he sort of adopted the positions
you can expect from anyone who
is going to run for the republican
nomination he
is of course well he says he is the
conservative candidate in this race
he is for school choice which is the
program that takes money and gives
students to go to private schools
instead and
is also for training programs for trade
our governor opposes school choice and
has failed to provide a plan to reduce
class size as governor i will block any
attempt
to force critical race theory on our
public school children
we can teach our children to respect
each other and treat everyone with
dignity
we must bring back a focus on trades so
nevada can attract good paying
manufacturing jobs
and we must do a better job of keeping
our best and brightest
right here in nevada so he's kind of
hinting a little bit about
some economic issues when he talks about
education and trade jobs
but what about the economy what about
addressing those issues yeah well it was
interesting because
you know this is his campaign
announcement he said right off the start
no new taxes that was his pledge there
promising to veto any new taxes that
could come his way
we have a governor and legislature
focused on protecting their own party
guaranteeing single party rule so they
can introduce state income tax
raise your property taxes and advance
public policy
that would make bernie sanders blush
well former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison introduced and endorsed
lombardo at rancho high school so
the sheriff has some political leaders
lining up behind him but north las vegas
mayor john lee
is also said that he is running for
governor former senator dean heller mark
ammade up north
they've been considering the same race
they're dipping their toe in the water a
little bit
anything that you've heard so far that
sort of separates
this pack of republicans as they're
looking up to line up against uh
governor sislek so the answer is not
really
one line of attack that may take on
lombardo is that
he stopped cooperating with immigration
officials after a court ruling so he
left what's called the 287 g
program and led to a whole thing about
then president trump calling las vegas a
sanctuary city for a little bit
by the way he said he would take an
endorsement from the president when i
asked him about it but he said
that he wasn't seeking it out he made
that sort of clear
i said are you seeking out the
nomination he said i'm not seeking it
but
i would take it it's a fine line and
it's still very early in the in the
governor's race we're still a long ways
out
governor steve sislak hasn't really
criticized his opponents yet he
certainly knows the sheriff and john lee
very well from being down here in
southern nevada
last week uh governor sisalek told me he
expected the main lines of attack
against him to be focused on the
pandemic
it's easy to sit back and be a monday
morning quarterback
uh you know when you come to these
situations this state faced a pandemic
that if
it comes once in a century now you can
watch interviews that we've had with
governor sislek and
north las vegas mayor john lee on 8 news
now including the discussion you had
with uh
sheriff joel lombardo governor candidate
joel embark there you go thanks david
appreciate it thanks
now governor sislek met with president
joe biden this week part of the western
governors association meeting
they talked about trying to prevent
wildfires and
working with the climate and energy
strategy and included a road map
initiative to include
more infrastructure for electric
vehicles trying to get some of that down
the line
now switching gears here the rise in
coronavirus cases in clark county has
governor sisalik
asking for the federal government for
more help he wants
fema to set up vaccination sites again
here in nevada
this comes as clark county currently has
the highest number of daily cases in the
entire u.s
and a stalled rate of vaccinations a
growing number of those cases are that
delta variant it's more contagious
the health district is sticking with
current cdc recommendations
so face masks are not mandated right now
we spoke with the southern nevada health
district which
has its focus on increasing the
vaccination rate
we consider that it's very important for
us to
emphasize the need for vaccination
for those people who have not received
the vaccine because
most of the the hospitalizations and
deaths that we are seeing today in craig
county
are from people who who are not
vaccinated
so here is specifically what the
governor has requested more
testing sites more expansive get out the
vaccine campaign and coming up with a
workplace vaccination program all to try
and get more people the coronavirus
vaccine
another delay in the execution of zane
floyd this week a federal judge ruled
floyd's attorneys
need more time to investigate the drugs
that would be used in the process so
there'll be a delay
the drug cocktail nevada's department of
corrections plans to use for this
execution has
never been tried floyd murdered four
people at a local albertson's back in
1999.
state prison officials had been
close-lipped tightlipped about what
drugs they were going to use
until this judge ordered them to reveal
it the execution was scheduled for later
this month but now it won't be until
october 18th if it happens at all nevada
has not executed a prisoner since
2004. president joe biden hit the road
this week to pitch his latest
infrastructure plan the new bipartisan
proposal is 973 billion dollars
most of the one million jobs created in
the plan would go to workers without a
college degree
however the bipartisan measure quickly
fell into disarray
the president said he would only sign it
if democrats also passed their own
separate infrastructure bill focused on
social and family welfare
well president biden later clarified
that wasn't a veto threat but
republicans still pushed back
he gets an agreement with republicans
and democrats on infrastructure
and in minutes later he blows the whole
thing up by cutting a side deal with
speaker pelosi and chuck schumer
trying to appease the most radical
elements of his base the president looks
forward to
signing each bill uh he's long supported
the two-track approach and his view is
that the american people
are most interested in what we're going
to do to deliver for them
republican leaders have not said whether
they plan to support the bipartisan
legislation on mass
nevada democratic congresswoman dina
titus sits on the committee currently
hearing that bill
she says the second proposal may have to
do
may have to all be passed in different
parts
you've got wi-fi that you need to expand
in areas that aren't served
and wi-fi is the electricity of today
it's essential to for education for
business for medicine so that's part of
it
and then we'll do a bigger package that
looks at human infrastructure whether
it's
child care or expanding medicare and i
want to see
all of those past and maybe in two
different vehicles
but now's the time to go big go bold or
go home
i don't see this as an expenditure but
rather as an investment
so far a vote has not been scheduled on
the infrastructure bill or the human
infrastructure bill referenced both
senators and all three congress people
from here in southern nevada
they're all democrats they do support
those measures
coming up next on politics now
investigating ufos
there needs to be a tremendous amount of
government
resources put into this up next we hear
from former senator harry reid and our
own george knapp about the big takeaways
from a government report
welcome back to politics now
[Music]
advanced technology and close calls
highlight a pentagon report a new one on
ufos
an executive summary was made public a
week ago the focus of this
report it's pretty narrow just recent
military encounters with unknown objects
from 2004 to 20 20
2021 there were 144 cases including the
famous tic tac
encounter that's the video you're seeing
right now 18 of the cases exhibited
unusual flight characteristics
former nevada senator harry reid was the
person who got the ball rolling
senator so it's finally out an
underwhelming nine pages
at least the public version of the
report what's your initial impressions
well the government has acknowledged
that they
don't know what these unidentified
flying objects are
and so when i started talking about this
years ago
people made fun of me and uh even my own
staff thought it was
crazy and talking about it but
in hindsight i'm glad i did certainly
we now know that there have been they
have 142 signings we know there have
been more than that
but it's something that as far as i'm
concerned this is a preliminary
report and i mean preliminary there
needs to be a tremendous amount of
government
uh resources put into this so we better
understand it so
so it's not some kind of a fringe
part of what government's doing they've
got to dive into this because
we and the american people are entitled
to know what the hell is going on
well we went straight to the expert to
ask about the report you just saw him
george knapp of the mr wire
and the i team they don't give a lot of
specifics they have broad numbers but no
specific cases
we can guess what they are the numbers
are interesting
144 cases that the u.s navy
office of naval intelligence analyzed
and 143 of those 144 cases
remain unidentified they said more than
half of those cases
have multiple sensor systems that were
involved that confirmed it was a real
physical object
it's not a cloud it's not a bird it's
something real that's flying around
uh they were very cautious in their
approach they're not saying these are
aliens they don't mention
extraterrestrials
they really don't know what they are but
uh
the bulk of them are really interesting
and that and some of them
are super interesting in that there were
11 cases where
um the pilots had near mid-air
collisions with physical objects which
would have been a disaster
there were 18 of these cases where
whatever these things are
they demonstrated remarkable technical
capabilities i mean they
they can they demonstrated really
incredible speeds
uh maneuverability that is beyond
anything we've got
so at a minimum it's interesting if it
is chinese
or russian technology that's a really
big deal i mean if the tic tac incident
that video we've all seen from 2004 if
that thing had a chinese decal slapped
on top of it
there would be a serious national
security matter so
they said admit you know we don't have
enough evidence to rule out
foreign technology we don't have enough
proof to rule out that it could be some
kind of sort of secret american
technology
uh from special access program but they
asked
they asked a whole long list of agencies
hey are these yours
and the answer was no uh so it's it's a
real shift for the pentagon to put out
even this limited report that says
this is a legitimate mystery it is a
national security matter
it is a concern for aerospace safety
so we should look into it it just stirs
up more questions
you know and is is it at a point now
where
there are no answers left is this all
the
the military has to give no
not not by a long shot there was a
report that was given to congress
behind closed doors a classified version
of this report
that's nine times larger we know from
some of the stories that we've leaked
the leaks that we've had in the stories
we've produced that they have visual
evidence that they have
visual images video shot by their navy
viper teams on these ships
that indicate these are some kind of
craft of the one the uss omaha now there
are three different videos released from
that
first you have the thermal image of the
sphere this big
six foot in diameter at least spear that
followed right along this u.s navy
warship
um for more than an hour there were and
then there's radar images that shows
there were as many as 14 of these things
that surrounded the ship at that same
time in fact
in a broader sense in that same time
period three days
in july of 2019 there were more than a
hundred of these objects that appeared
around nine u.s navy warships they don't
know what they are
it is a legitimate mystery that deserves
to be investigated
i i think that you probably could uh
identify some of these things if you put
some
money and resources into it the uap task
force that produced this report
um they had two staff members two
part-time staff members
who worked on it in a six-month time
period here you go
u.s navy produce a story or a report
that
encapsulates 74 years of ufo information
in a mere six months so they put almost
no resources at all and had no budget
the report that was just released to the
public suggests
we need to put some money into this
create an organization that acts as a
central belly button
and force all these other government
agencies to start cooperating
we have a lot more information about the
report the videos the incidents
all of it is at mysterywire.com coming
up on politics now
the final two supreme court opinions of
the term show just how much
influence the conservative majority will
have the final two supreme court
opinions of the most recent term make it
pretty clear how much influence the
conservative majority will have on the
high bench
alex simone has details on some of the
most major rulings
in a six to three opinion the supreme
court struck down california's
requirement for charities and nonprofits
to disclose the names of their top
donors
conservative and liberal groups opposed
california's law
and the supreme court agreed
california's requirement
violated donor's first amendment right
these are
organizations that are operating the
public domain that are actually
advocating for public policy changes and
in some cases actually advocating for
certain candidates
michael cohen ceo of cohen research
group and
author of modern political campaigns
says this case now opens the door for
other lawsuits to directly challenge
campaign finance laws
in another decision the conservative
justices also upheld two controversial
voting laws in arizona
one allows the state to throw out
ballots cast in the wrong precinct
another blocks third parties from
collecting ballots
a federal appeals court in san francisco
had blocked arizona's laws saying they
disproportionately
impact black hispanic and native
american voters
but justice samuel alito wrote that the
state's interest in
election integrity justify the measures
democrats like florida congressman
darren soto say
congress needs to pass new reforms the
right to vote is under attack by state
legislatures
by the supreme court and we need to pass
h.r 1 the for the people act
or the very least passed the john lewis
voting rights act but the measures are
unlikely to pass
in the narrowly divided senate in
washington
alexandra limon our washington d.c
correspondent alexander limon joining us
now to explain
why the justices ruled that way alex
what are some of the larger
repercussions that this ruling could
have
hey there well the conservative supreme
court justices
agreed with the groups that were
challenging california's law saying that
forcing
charities and non-profits to disclose
the names of their top donors
could have a chilling effect and and
prevent those donors
from making their donations and the
justices actually said that
california's requirement was infringing
on the first amendment rights of those
donors
however on the flip side of that coin
it's important to note that both
conservative groups like the americans
for prosperity foundation as well as
liberal groups like the aclu
were opposed to california's law and
and the reason for that is that it
doesn't just necessarily
impact straightforward groups that you
would typically consider
you know a charity like the american
cancer foundation
it it impacts all sorts of non-profits
that sometimes
uh you know may fundraise for certain
political causes
maybe even sometimes for political
candidates and so
other groups who were supportive of
california's law and political observers
worry
that this supreme court ruling may now
make campaign
finance laws or campaigns less
transparent
and actually open the door for a lot
more lawsuits to come forward in the
future
more directly you know trying to fight
campaign finance laws and challenge
those laws
because of this very ruling and alex in
another major case the supreme court
upheld two
controversial voting laws in arizona
what made those laws so controversial
well one of the reasons they were so
controversial and this ruling is a bit
controversial is that actually
the lower federal court that last ruled
on this case found that those
arizona voting laws disproportionately
impacted black hispanic and native
american voters
and were in violation of the 1965 voting
rights
act and those laws in arizona they did
two things
one is they allowed the state to throw
out any ballots that were cast
in the wrong precinct but secondly it
also
banned what the state of arizona calls
ballot harvesting that's going to do a
couple of things for starters
states around the country conservative
states could choose to take both of
those exact same laws and
implement them in their states because
they know that they can
no longer be challenged in court that's
already been settled but it again also
opens the door
and emboldens those uh republican or
conservative legislators around the
country that we've seen
are currently trying to pass hundreds of
different laws to
restrict voting in various ways it
emboldens them to try to move forward
even more so with those
laws with the hopes that the supreme
court in the end would uphold those laws
too
well tomorrow is america's our
independence day so we want to wish
all of you a happy fourth of july of
course now there are a bunch of
celebrations around nevada there's the
summerlin patriotic parade that was
earlier today
the boulder city danbury is also
tomorrow and after a year and a half of
being
locked in at home everybody ready to
celebrate there are fireworks shows
happening up and down the strip
downtown las vegas henderson summerlin
and the rural corners of clark county
plenty of places to celebrate our
nation's independence
we thank you very much for watching
politics now we'll see you next week
take care of yourselves
[Music]